ROBERT KUBIS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see what's
new with Cloud Spanner,
then stay tuned, because
here's the Rewind.
Cloud Spanner is Google's
answer to have it all.
No compromises on
performance, horizontal scale,
strong consistency by having
familiar relational semantics,
schemas, and SQL.
And the best, it comes as
a fully managed service
available in 13 Google
Cloud Platform regions.
Over the last year,
many things got added.
We have expanded to more
regions around the globe,
added admin and
data access logging,
more metrics and integrations
into Stackdriver.
For instance, the open
census integration
for better
observability, and also
added multiple compliance
certifications.
Another cool new feature
is commit timestamps,
which is heavily used
internally and was
asked for by our customers.
Commit timestamps allow
you to transactionally log
when a transaction has committed
as part of your modified rows.
But we didn't stop there.
More features are
launching to improve
manageability and
development on Cloud Spanner.
Supported by demos from
Deepti and colleagues,
they show the new push button
import/export functionality
for disaster recovery or
moving data between databases
for development and testing.
Next, you get a sneak preview
into a long-awaited feature,
like DML, which
allows you to run
complex queries with conditional
updates directly from the UI.
DML will also enable
full-fledged JDBC driver
support coming soon.
Another feature previewed
are query statistics,
which allows you to get insights
into your worst-performing
and most expensive SQL queries
for better application insights
and performance tuning.
During the talk, Deepti
invites Nexus Health,
a customer on Cloud Spanner.
Nexus Health has built their
own electronic medical record
system, called
Clinical Workstation,
on top of positional databases.
It became so popular that
over 30 hospitals in Belgium
started using it.
Managing that complex system
with high availability
requirements has
become a burden.
So to support the rapid growth
with the need for reliability
and availability
while concentrating
on building the application
rather than maintaining
the infrastructure,
Nexus Health has
started building the
next version of MOAPR,
Mother Of All Patient Records,
on top of Cloud Spanner.
If this sparked your interest,
please watch the full talk.
And if you're ready
to dive deeper
into improving your applications
built on Cloud Spanner,
check out my talk on optimizing
applications, schemas,
and query design.
Links to both talks can be
found in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]